I've just sent the better of
my hot plates to Japan.
None of this stuff is
quite straight.
This is my apparatus for, which
we're going to use to
light a match with water.
Sounds an improbable thing to
do, but that's what's going to
happen hopefully.
I have never actually done this
before, so maybe it won't
happen, but we'll see.
So we're going to boil water
in here, over a Bunsen.
The steam is going to boil off,
flow through these tubes,
into the coil, and out here.
And while it's flowing around
the coil, we're going to try
and superheat it with
a blowtorch.
So when it comes out, it's
a few hundred degrees
centigrade.
And hopefully that will be
enough to light a match.
Of course it would have been
helpful if I'd filled that
from the hot tap.
Oop.
Classic schoolboy error.
OK.
That will take a couple
minutes to come
to the boil, I think.
You can't normally light
a match with
water, or even steam.
Because it's just
not hot enough.
The normal steam you get off
boiling water will condense
pretty much immediately on
anything because it's only
just above its boiling point.
So as soon as it hits anything
cooler, it will just condense.
It's getting hotter
quickly, actually.
We want to really heat
the steam up to
a few hundred degrees.
At which point, hopefully we'll
exceed the autoignition
temperature of the head
of the match.
So the head will have a
temperature at which, if you
raise it to that temperature, it
will spontaneously ignite.
And that's what we're
trying to do.
Just to heat this water hot
enough that that will happen.
OK.
So the thermometer is
reading quite a lot
less than 100 degrees.
But that's probably not
really a surprise.
We've got this huge coil, which
at the moment is acting
like a condenser.
So we're probably not getting
water above 100
degrees out the end.
Which is where the blowtorch
comes in.
So you saw just now, before I
started using the blowtorch,
there was a lot of condensed
water dripping out
the end of the pipe.
The plume of droplets, the plume
of water mist that you
saw coming out as the water
condensed, is now pretty much
disappeared completely.
Because it's now too hot, and
it's not condensing when it
comes out at the end
of the pipe.
It's a bit of a problem juggling
all these extremely
hot objects.
But - I'll probably just
take the blowtorch
away while I do this.
Oh.
Not bad.
I've never seen a match
do that before.
It sort of smoldered
without igniting.
Didn't know that was possible.
I wasn't convinced that
there was enough
heating going on there.
So I've got another
Bunsen out.
We'll see how we get
on with that.
So I've set the water
boiling off again.
Let's light this other Bunsen.
Now we've got our copper coil
actually glowing red hot.
So I think this is going
to do the job now.
I don't think it is that
easy to melt copper.
I think it'll radiate a
lot of heat before it
gets to that point.
OK.
So let's give the thermometer
a go.
See if we're - see how
hot we might be.
It's really racing up.
Nope.
Hm.
I see.
Well, I've learned something
new today.
I've learnt that my thermometer
only goes up to
200 degrees.
So we've maxed it out.
Oh.
There we go.
That's a really interesting
observation, actually.
And I think that the problem we
had before was not so much
that it wasn't hot enough, but
that I was just holding the
match too directly in
the stream of steam.
And not pulling out as it
started to smolder.
And obviously, there is
no oxygen in what's
coming out of here.
This is pure gaseous water.
So there's no oxygen there.
So the match wasn't actually
able to ignite.
And I think that was probably
the problem.
And now: A, we've increased
the heat.
But B, if I just stick it into
the stream and then withdraw
it, to allow the air to
get to it, at that
point the match ignites.